spring in Shan Salisbury great NFL
analyst former NFL quarterback host of
the Shawn Salisbury show on Sports Talk
790 in Houston good morning Sean come on
unless you guys talk the first two words
I hear a pink slip and get cut just a
coincidence just a coincidence expert
okay
whoo-hoo you got more confidence in to
win a playoff game the Bears or the
Texans right now I'm going with offense
we'll go at the end of the I take the
weakness of both teams when I'm trying
to say okay this defense is great
Chicago the defense and the Texans is
really really good then I go okay well
what's next and I think Watson's better
and risky at this point I do believe I
had in August I said true Biscay would
make Jared Goff like leaps this year and
love the Bears I think they're going to
win the division I think they're
dangerous because they're set up for
January it can run it good enough their
defense is nasty and I think troduce
keying their weapons are getting better
but I like I think the AFC on the lower
end is weaker I think that the deshaun
Watson so dynamic that even if things
aren't going well he can still pull it
out and I don't say I think for because
you're two away from that kind of guy
although I love his strides I would say
the Texans because they're also
confident I I don't I like the sound
Watson when it comes down to it then
I'll always choose the quarterback if
everything is equal I like the Texans a
little bit more to get at least one
playoff victory for comparing the two
but they've won eight in a row it's it
sounds strange to go I'm still not sure
and and I'm still not sure with them
even though they want to eight in a row
what's it gonna take that goal what's it
gonna take to convince me that the
Texans are a legitimate Superbowl
caliber team domination in January in a
game and then I think what you're going
through is the same thing we talked
about on my show every day and the
people here are they're still kind of
going at this with trepidation because
of the eight straight wins seven over
six of them were kind of ugly and we now
you watch a Monday night game like the
Rams and the Chiefs you look at the
Chiefs for more love even though plays
better this year for a loss a pretty
loss then you will the Texans for an
ugly win and they've won a lot of ugly
ways you know they beat the Dolphins you
know pretty handily and last night was
probably their prettiest one of the
eight but I think is there at the eight
of them day and I think it's because
they're kind of boring at times Watson
makes them less boring they you know
sometimes they'll punt on fourth down
although they look for it last night
they don't do anything they don't extend
themselves from from other teams they
keep things close last night was
probably the most impressive win with
the way they did it but I'm with you I
still go out and I think people here
like yeah I find it and find it any
wonder then do in January and I think
that hangs over their heads until they
physically and and you know finesse lies
dominate a team of January you're gonna
feel like that even if they won 12 in a
row would you rather have the best
offensive line or the best defensive
line in football was my quarterback I
can't tell you that
yeah okay probably if I think we look at
the Texans case in point since we're on
that very very average at best up front
you got a quarterback who's so dynamic
even though he takes for four sacks you
still able to make plays on 3rd and 12
fourth and 14 I wish I could Apple so
right now you go what's the second most
need for me if I'm drafting a team
quarterback first disruption second I
need disruption chaos and the guys on
defense like Khalil Mack that group they
create chaos you saw with clowny and
those guys were doing to the to
Tennessee last night and what I need
chaos so I probably go quarterback
because I would trust him to direct
protection properly to we can max
protect I can cover those guys a little
more but I can't cover a bad front 7
because it could gashed in a run game
and they can't rush the passer I'll take
the disrupter second I'll go defensive
front seven second we spent a lot of
time we're talking to Shawn Salisbury we
were spending time in the first 10
minutes of the show and we got into the
Jacksonville Jaguars because fournette
got suspended Blake bortles has been
demoted offensive coordinator has been
fired this
a team that was a couple plays away from
going to the Super Bowl last year and
now you have a bad locker room and I
don't know how you clean up a bad locker
room if you if you don't have confidence
in a quarterback you just gave an
extension to like how would you how
would you troubleshoot the Jacksonville
Jaguars in the offseason and here is
this August and that the guys was in the
front office is like we would never
think it would allow trouble to seep in
and Tom Coughlin and I don't think he'll
let it seep in long but you're gonna
have to do is you're gonna even though
he was in the AFC champion he's gonna
have to look long and hard and evaluate
does Marone and everybody in the
organization first thing I do is I'll
trim the fat man if you're not part of
it out you're out because I can go 3 and
13 or 6 and 10 with a bunch of good
locker room guys it may not be as
talented I look at the Jacksonville
Jaguars and they got there last year in
spite of mortals the anok was defense
but you know what they're there that guy
that when they're in front of you that
sprinter he's got you by 10 meters he
looks over his shoulder and smirks at
you in 100 meter the 200 meter but
they're also that team that when they're
come out of the blocks late and they're
down 15 meters in the 200 meter they
grab the hammy
gotta go I think that you know that go I
can't quite catch I think they're a
great front running team but they hit
some adversity and can't handle it and
the quarterbacks got a a wind up that
slow as a ferris wheel and they haven't
been able to overcome that you know it's
five times they have and then their
defense which is supposed to be dominant
you got guys looking over their shoulder
and looking at another guy they're more
worried about Edie interviews and crowd
and point fingers with all that talent
than they are getting it fixed so I
think you have to evaluate from the top
on down and if guys aren't on I don't
care I'd look to trade some of the guys
they don't want to be a part of it and I
see what kind of assets I can get
because a bad locker room people say
what comes first winning or chemistry
probably winning but it just goes to
show you this is a great front running
team but if you can't win a Super Bowl
offensively right now in this league
we're in and with some of their was with
some of the different characters it's
okay to have some of those types of guys
in your locker room if you got strong
leadership above them the problem is
they don't the Jacksonville Jaguars need
an overhaul
Tom Coughlin is gonna have to make some
tough decisions easy a quarterback but
tough with the coach and some other guys
you're gonna they'll make as many
Changez this offseason is anything like
that and also looking at the draft
because we always think the answers are
in the draft and if you're looking at
these quarterbacks I mentioned you know
you got Haskins at Ohio State Greer West
Virginia Oh Herbert at Oregon I I don't
know
in a regular draft you know in previous
years are these guys first-round draft
picks I don't know but sometimes we look
at a quarterback will elevate a
quarterback if there's just not that
many options there and I don't know if
we're gonna do that this year so I don't
know if Jacksonville's answers in the
draft or the Giants answers is in the
draft how do you see that with these
these quarterbacks and is anybody gonna
be able to help anybody right away I
think you know when you look at guys
like Herbert and houses are big and
strong I think they're it's premature
for us to throw them an optics wise it
looks to me like it's a weak a
quarterback the depth but every year Dan
will over rate a couple guys and under
eight somewhere some dude will come in
the fourth ground get a chance to play
and we'll say how did we miss so I'm
sure that will happen but just depth
wise I don't think there's going to be
as much dancer or chatter about this
class of being dominant we're not having
as many guys drafted as high as we did
last year there'll be one or two but I
don't think any of them look to me like
they can come in and change a program
change the football team as a rookie for
me I think you've got to start you've
got to start to scour if you're the
Giants with Jacksonville and say what
what what the perception of the star
quarterback that's out there that's a
guy like Matt Stafford who puts up
numbers maybe he's run his course in
Detroit because they just I mean they're
just stopped and they've been doing this
for year after a while you know becomes
insane to keep beating your head against
the wall and things don't change they've
got a high payroll quarterback with
great skill set who could use him
well Jacksonville could use them because
you know bortles can't dress in the same
locker and the stafford yet staff hasn't
won a playoff game so guys like that i
think there's more opportunity again and
trying to look with what's currently in
the NFL to change your franchise if
you're at Jacksonville as your Giants
and and go about it that way and see
who's gonna give up guys that they
thought Jameis Winston baby Tampa says
now he's not for us he's not a hundred
million dollar guy so we got to move on
and maybe the venue change will help him
so
I think you're far better off trying to
see what's in the trade market then you
want to thinking a young guy right away
it can turn your team around especially
if you're a team that thinks you're on
the cusp of winning the division are
going to the playoffs
it's a quarterback League you got to
have a minute you don't you better be in
the 2000 Baltimore Ravens and we don't
have that type of defense the NFL right
good to visit with you Sean thanks for
joining us as always talk to you soon at
Sean soles bearing form NFL quarterback
host of the Sean Salsbury show on sports
2790 in Houston every afternoon for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]